turning now to the threats to the
Homeland investigators are still asking
for the Public's help to determine if
this hooded man from an Isis propaganda
video is an American or a Canadian due
to his accent which appears to be North
American the FBI is asking for the
Public's help to identify this man
joining us now talk more about the
Americans abroad fighting alongside the
terrorists and their recruitment efforts
underway the director of jihad watch
Robert Spencer welcome sir great to have
you here
today
thank you for having me on um let's talk
about what the FBI has been doing uh
over the last few days asking for the
Public's help in trying to identify this
individual what can you tell us about
what you know so far about that effort
are people coming forward with
information no uh there has not been any
notable response to the FBI's request
which is interesting in light of the
fact that American Muslim groups have
actually advised Muslims in mosques not
to talk to the FBI not to cooperate the
uh California chapter of the uh Hamas
link Council on American Islamic
relations actually distributed posters a
few years back saying don't talk to the
FBI and so it's not really surprising
that there hasn't been a level of
cooperation that one would expect or
that one would need from Muslim groups
in the United States uh the uh American
Muslims are joining the Islamic State
despite condemnations of that group from
Muslim leaders in the US in larger
numbers we ever saw with Jihad groups
like Al-Qaeda or as shabab or others uh
it seems as if the the claim that they
have restored the caliphate is
extraordinarily appealing and uh that
has not been addressed by authorities or
by Muslim leaders in the US now if the
situations uh continue to unfold as
we've been reporting and uh towns like
kobani fall that's only going to
encourage more people uh here in this
country um to perhaps join the
fight
oh absolutely the caliphate is a might
makes right proposition if the uh
Islamic state is able to take kabani and
able to continue to consolidate its
control over a territory that is
actually larger right now than the size
of the United Kingdom uh then they're
going to attract still more Muslims from
the United States from Canada from
Western Europe because uh the the idea
of the caliphate is that he's the
success the caleff is the successor of
Muhammad as the political and spirit ual
leader of the Muslims this is a claim
that is uh proven by the reality of the
kff wielding political power and so the
longer the Islamic State exists and the
more territory it's able to keep and
hold the more Muslims from outside its
environs it's going to attract now you
say that us Muslims who have gone to
join the Islamic Army are not notably
poor or marginalized that this is more
about religion and this is something
that is par amount in terms of their
quest to be part of
this oh absolutely the the restoration
of the caliphate is the fundamental
aspiration of all the Jihad groups
around the world Al-Qaeda Boko Haram as
shabab all of them and the Islamic state
has gotten a jump on all of them by
actually claiming to have done so have
have have succeeded in uh realizing this
goal and so it's not that it's the poor
and the marginalized that they're
appealing to it's to educated and devout
Muslims and so this is why when Barack
Obama says the Islamic state has nothing
to do with Islam it's so very damaging
and misleading instead he should be
calling upon Muslim groups in the United
States to confront this understanding of
Islam not just with condemnations but
with active programs to teach against it
in mosques and Islamic schools but that
is not being done and at this point from
uh what you've been able to determine
you feel that there are a number of
Americans that are hoping to join the
fight at this point and travel
overseas oh no doubt about it absolutely
uh we know that there are as many as a
100 who've already gone and uh this idea
is so appealing that we're going to see
many more unless and until there are
active efforts and programs in mosques
and Islamic schools to explain to Young
Muslims why they should reject this
understanding of Islam then this is
going to be a steady stream as it was
with the Somali Muslims in Minneapolis
going to join as shabab but that was
more ethnically based they were a Somali
community and they were going to fight
in Somalia this is an appeal that has uh
shown itself to have power with converts
to Islam from American backgrounds as
well as from uh people from ethnic
Muslim backgrounds uh people from uh
immigration backgrounds from Pakistan
and Iraq and so on uh we have seen both
of these groups going to the Islamic
State already and it's just going to
keep on all right Robert Spencer always
a pleasure thank you so much for joining
us
today thank you appreciate it